you have an extensive sex scene in the
movie and I it's my job to ask about
these things and I'm just curious when
you're exposing your body or parts of
your body how for how long are you
exposed or is it something that you that
happens very quickly but we shot that
that's the particular scene for two days
straight
two days two full days of that and you
would go to work nude and come home to
you know it wasn't like we were you know
the musical hair or something dancing
around yeah totally naked there were
moments where that happened and it was
disarming to just there was just a
you're just but is out there there's the
camera crew and that's what right and so
but that just you know it had to happen
you just deal with it and you're an
actor you do it well I was more honestly
I was more concerned about Rosamund Pike
because she was we were having sex in
the scene so I just wanted to make sure
that she in her own state of disarray
bidness felt comfortable and didn't feel
weird right and and make sure no one
really really saw my Wang
it's important sounds like you to you we
were very you showed a lot of concern
there as an actor but yeah you know we
don't want you don't mind a little like
a hint of the Wang right I just don't
want just a long along along so that was
you know you're conscious of that right
right like I'm fine if you see my butt
and stuff like that
right and but you know don't get the
camera too low
right then have it slowly move up and
around it's like a puppet show what
you've done nudity on stage yes yeah
yeah actually in LA I did a play John
Robbie baitz play called the Paris
letter where I had to come out it was
actually with Josh Radnor who was on How
I Met Your Mother
right played Ted and we this was before
then and we it was a flashback scene in
the 70s where I had seduced him we had
just had sex and the scene starts with
him coming on naked and nervous that wow
what have I done and then I kind of
saunter on as well naked so did these
stage directions say saunter or was that
was very 70s like yeah yeah saunter II
yeah and so yeah we were both people
like off stage left doing the windmill
and stuff the helicopter
why make sure it wasn't you know it was
what it was looking good that wouldn't
help me would not get me in that state
doing the windmill I would just be
winded the helicopter oh my god
that's the most you're the most
complimentary mime you just did the
people are walking by six feet away Wow
you